hi everybody congratulations you've
already graduated now you're going to
graduate again I'd like an applause for
our Columbia University jazz ensemble is
amazing amazing young players there are
fellow students so welcome welcome to
everybody to graduating students parents
friends our dedicated faculty and staff
and our guest Tony Kushner
we'll say more about him soon first I
need to congratulate the class of 2011
with graduating students representing 31
countries we've marveled at your
brilliance and your talent and your
warmth and your compassion and your
camaraderie and your achievements we
have emerged ourselves in your work
we've bonded with you as our students
and we bond with you now is our
colleagues and thus we're very sad to
see them but we are also happy because
we know that you are extremely extremely
well prepared to enter your professions
and we're certain that you're going to
make us very proud we were thrilled to
see your accomplishments throughout your
time with us and most recently at
panoply 2011 where so many of you shared
readings and performances and screenings
and exhibitions and thank you to the IAC
for coordinating all that and we saw you
a trip brilliantly directed theatre
thesis plays and the actors thesis
productions I'm at the new place now
festival it's me like a dog and Tribeca
at the film festival at the ifc
Directors Guild of America mcgraw-hill
Theatre Royal theatres and here at
Miller for a first-ever student choice
evening with the miraculous range of new
short films and screenplays
we have enjoyed the beautifully produced
writers thesis anthology with selections
from every second year MFA student I
leave marveled at the spectacular and
might I say monumental visual arts
thesis exhibition of the Fisher Landau
center in Long Island City
you are a really easy audience OHS what
you're not don't make me there okay
these events have been thrilling and not
only to us but to the thousands really
thousands of people who attended them
the thousands of people who will read
your work and who have appreciated them
and appreciated you and will continue to
as graduates you'll be joining an
incredibly illustrious group of alumni
who have gone on to extraordinary
achievements all around the world and
this year the overall successes of our
students and graduates is once again
it's really overwhelming too extravagant
to enumerate year so I've chosen just a
few representations from each of the
programs so in film Lisa told danko won
Best Screenplay for the kids are all
right these are all alums the film was
distributed by focus features which is
headed by from Professor James Sheamus
the kids were all right was also
nominated for four Academy Awards
including Best Picture and Best
Screenplay the Spirit Awards robert
altman award was given to the one in
film's director casting director at its
ensemble cast and this was awarded to
Nicole hold the center who for her film
please give for alumni fills was
selected to screen at the new directors
new film festival presented by the film
society of lincoln center and the Museum
of Modern Art and the two features were
a man without a cell phone and outbound
and two shorts natch and the you keep
all of our alumni and film in theater
arts the theater arts program alumni
collaboration when last we flew one a
glaad media award in March the play was
written produced and marketed all by
Columbia loans to play writing alumni
abba nominated for outer circle awards
for outstanding new off-broadway plays
that's shiva duran for kin and Tommy
nobili for blood from a stone and in
Visual Arts in the first week in May six
visual arts alumni had solo exhibitions
running
galleries sean da da shishkin mac keygen
Hilary Harnish beggar Nicola Lopez Peter
mantra' Jeff and for students and one
alumni have been awarded 2012 emerging
artist fellowships from socrates
sculpture park Naja Frank jessi
greenberg Nick peperone Walter venome
Smith who are all graduating today and
alumni Jessica Segal in writing for
writing alumni alumni were chosen as the
new york magazine's 20 under 40 fiction
writers worth watching rifka galcon dena
me get sue karen russell and wells tower
and 2010-11 apparelsave segal was
awarded the prestigious Nona valakians
citation for excellence in viewing at
this year's national book critics circle
awards so these are just recent alums
and some of these students who are
sitting here today lots of achievements
this year our alumni are everywhere
working hard every day producing
extraordinary work in a short time all
of you graduating today will become part
of the great story of success that is
the School of the Arts remember please
keep in touch tell us about your
accomplishments so that we can brag
about you to friends and colleagues at
the University and to the rest of the
world and I can mention you at
graduation ceremonies like this one and
we also want to continue to be helpful
to you in any way we can you will always
be part of the School of the Arts and up
from the University in the city of New
York no matter where your lives take you
no matter where your work takes you the
student body in total represents 48
countries we cherish the breadth and
depth of this mix we have learned so
much from your presence we now await the
world's recognition
newtown's before we begin today our
program I would like to acknowledge
those people without whom any of you
could never have completed this most
essential part of your work and that is
your parents and your families and your
friends so let's have the families and
the friends of our graduates please
stand
and now let's ask our really brilliant
faculty wonderful artists all who have
mentored all of you graduating today and
your work with love and dedication and
deep concern to please stand where the
faculty
over there on the left in that mix of
faculty is Richard Locke and I wanted I
want to give a special acknowledgement
to writing faculty Richard Locke who was
chosen this year to receive one of the
2011 presidential awards for outstanding
teaching now these awards are from
students to you so it's particularly
meaningful and very coveted among the
faculty I want to read just very very
brief the closing part of the citation
which Richard will would will be online
which we will receive this is what was
said about them this is just the last
two paragraphs the value of your
unstinting support of efforts can be
gauged by the scores of books you have
had a hand in shepherding towards
publication yet you are modest declared
one student in the way of those who
demand the excellence of others by
practicing it themselves in all you have
given your students the invaluable
experience of a hands-on editor the area
addition of a scholar and the engagement
of a critic it is our pleasure to
confirm you the university's highest
educational award the 2011 presidential
award for outstanding teaching we're
very proud which is really
now I'd like to thank the staff who
helped make this program possible today
first labor mayor and Anthony came from
our extraordinary Office of Student
Affairs to this is Chanku Kamara kenny
wong and it's a fool that poor scared
demon our wonderful directors of
academic administration from each
program on stage with us bill wadsworth
Emma balazs julie rossi and sarah nelson
those in communications and events and
bird Miriam buyer Daisy nom Joe Turner
then and all those at Miller as well as
those of the nemeth center and the
dean's office I'd also like to thank
faculty Chris Washburn and once again
the Columbia University jazz ensemble
fabulous group that give their time to
us every year we thank as well maybe we
should apply
of course we thank all the student
volunteers many who have helped as well
as our coordinators of the event I
director of the ceremony today's Ashley
Kelly Tata as well as our stage monitor
any Steinman marijuana there's a theater
student center helped us enormously it
looks a lot better not only my theater
people involved in theater the
commencement assistant Suzanne Moses and
always I would like to thank Dean
Barbara bachelor and my partner in crime
our amazing dean of academic
administration Jenna right ok let's
begin opening our program today is our
guest speaker Tony Kushner a fellow
Colombian a graduate of Columbia College
and awarded an award last year
presidential alumni medal of excellence
at graduation is one of the greatest
playwrights this country or any country
has ever produced courageous really in
provocative a man of honor and a great
humor a great advocate for freedom of
expression in all forms is an honor to
have him with us today and in to
introduce Tony Kushner we've asked
Arnold Aronson chair of the theater arts
program author of many books on
sonography set design in theater history
to introduce him to you Arnel Aronson
people just say that to like introduce
you later in discussing whom we should
invite to speak at today's graduation we
said it's someone quiet and
non-controversial I'm sorry that's
queuing oh of course that is precisely
what we did not want which is why we
invited playwright Tony Kushner this is
a school of the arts and what is the
purpose of art if not to provoke
stimulate challenge and question to make
you think our speaker this afternoon has
said that going to the theater raises
the audience is collective IQ 25 points
this cannot be an absolute truth i have
seen plays that do the opposite but
certainly when you see a play by Tony
Kushner one of the most extraordinarily
intellectual great playwrights of the
contemporary theater your mind is
stretched in new directions some 13 or
14 years ago I had the pleasure of
hosting an evening with Arthur Miller on
this stage and now I have the honor of
introducing Tony Kushner for me
personally to be able to introduce to
the greatest playwrights in American
theatre history is astonishing and
humbling but the fact that it is these
two playwrights is significant because
they share certain sensibility
intellectual breadth political
engagement and a view of morality both
are concerned with the complexities and
contradictions of individual
responsibility with the consequences of
human actions with the state of society
with making the world a better place for
the future with the ineluctable
entanglements of politics
and human relations and lest we forget
about love and family most important i
think they tackled big themes American
Theatre with only a few notable
exceptions has been a small theatre our
writers and audiences alike seemed all
too comfortable with petty family
squabbles individual psychology and what
happens in the bedroom in the kitchen
but too often such plays are incapable
of moving beyond the confines of those
rooms Tony Kushner's plays cannot be
contained within four walls even when he
creates a room he has an angel crash
through the wall sending blaster and
dust everywhere his most recent play the
intelligent homosexuals guide to
capitalism and socialism with a key to
the scriptures is actually set in a
Brooklyn brownstone mostly in a living
room and a few other locales but despite
its apparent of domestic trappings it is
not a small play it deals with all the
nouns in the title plus an extensive
disposition on labor unions the
economics of sex multi-generational
family dynamics real estate and very
detailed instructions on how to commit
suicide by asphyxiation probably most
people know Tony Kushner for the
two-part Angels in America but like all
artists or performers who burst onto the
scene it was a long gestation by my
count there were 14 other plays before
Angels the play that put him on the map
was a bright room called day in which
can be seen many of the ideas and themes
that pervade later work the play is set
during the collapse of the by my
Republican Germany and the rise of
Hitler which is set in counterpoint to
the presidency of Ronald Reagan and the
implementation of Republican policies
but it is not a play about facile
comparisons it is about the knee
the individual in society to take
responsibility for what happens in that
society and I must mention my favorite
play from the pre angels period hi
joseph e.m from 1987 a mere 167 pages it
deals with a minor historical figure
from england during the time of Cromwell
who but Kushner could create a play from
such material as you know his other work
includes essays musicals opera and the
film unit directed by Steven Spielberg
finally I MO as the current play
sometimes called has garnered glowing
reviews but if there has been a
criticism it is that the play is
sprawling the brilliantly overlapping
dialogue and family scenes is hard to
follow as it is in all our families and
some characters speak and intellectually
dense paragraphs one of the main
characters who's been working on his
dissertation for 30 years says I'm
afraid of the Delete key presumably this
is twenty kushner himself speaking and
if so I for one hope that he never gets
over that fear there is so much
brilliant work coming out of his mind
and conveyed to us through the mouths of
fascinating characters that I would take
his sprawling challenging plays any day
okay just we're disregarding a
commencement speakers principal
responsibility which is the dispensing
of good advice from the last minute
reinforcement of ideals towards which
you already graduated students barely
ought to and hopefully will as father
after you've left as you will do after
the ceremony the growth of academia are
out in the jungle being assaulted by
wild beasts and poisonous stinging
insects underfoot and snared and vines
that produce hideous rashes on contact
struggling onwards towards those ideals
and aspirations against the dawning
realization that as your hunger pains
worsen and your you blister and shrivel
from exposure although you have learned
much of immense value about the virtues
and drawbacks of digicams versus
35-millimeter panic Lexi's and pursue
acting objectives and building dramatic
narrative and the technical challenges
of lithography you have perhaps acquired
in sufficient skill in pursuing and
trapping and preparing food or building
shelter disregarding my responsibility
is your commencement speaker to remind
you of the ideals you should have in
mind while you're being devoured by an
inhospitable ecosystem hungry for the
minerals and proteins and fatty acids
you contain disregarding the
unreasonable expectation that i will
present myself to you with a reason of
the straight face as an exemplar of what
a working artist are to be it's
unreasonable because
just opened a show have another one
beginning previews and we writing a film
script and I wish I was dead I'm elected
to begin by confessing into a bad habit
I've stopped reading newspapers I used
to read at least one or two newspapers
every day but over the course of the
past several years I'd slackened and now
I almost never do unless something truly
horrendous it's really extraordinary it
happens it goes without saying we all
know it but I'll say it anyway the truly
horrendous happens much more often than
the truly extraordinary and the truly
extraordinary is often adulterated with
potential to transform by the next
morning's edition of New York Times and
why be about the bush when I say a
newspaper I mean new york times we used
to the other daily newspapers but now
there's men at the Times those other
things that there are also those other
things that seem like newspapers if
they're printed on cheap paper and they
get your fingers inky if you hold them
for too long but they're not actually
newspapers at all just new camouflage
for the sucker tentacles of one of the
scariest of all the jungle predators and
also visit Daily News god bless it gives
you live on Long Island Newsday both of
which the aforementioned predator hasn't
consumed her killed Bishop perhaps
instead of too much for survival which
is in the long run never an
accomplishment in president of the truly
extraordinary as I was saying is usually
a doctor any with potential to transform
into the truly horrendous while the
truly horrendous although theoretically
occasion for the opportunities with
which crises theoretically present us is
most often manifestly pregnant with the
potential for the even more horrendous
and compel to I will read the newspaper
but mostly I avoided this is a terrible
thing when I have taught playwriting
I've always told my students they have
to read newspapers every day and this is
very good advice and you should follow
it even though I seem to have strayed
I've become very busy and
married to a journalist who reads
everything every newspaper every
magazine on and off line every day and
like half an hour I'm a slow reader
might become a terrible wimp about
assimilating new horrors and so I've
become preoccupied with history instead
with old horrors and so I've lapsed
opportunistically into waiting for my
husband to tell me what's going on this
means for instance that I was two days
later than everyone else in learning
that former governor and fellow artists
on Schwarzenegger that's not an exemplar
of the kind murica to dispense
disordered advice that recommends him as
a commencement speaker though that's the
honest and admit that if he was your
commencement speaker all the other
schools at Columbia would envy you he
would be electrifying even if not
edifying and even if on certain words to
which he still at umlauts a little hard
to understand many years ago I met a
psychologist who had written a book that
was an important contribution to the
period when the feminist revolution
broadened and sharpened its radical
reconsideration of the nature of gender
this psychologist shocked me when I met
her by telling me that she never read a
newspaper happened in years because she
realized that her friends her community
would keep her abreast of everything
important that happens it even better
that the hard work of parsing the news
leading with the critical eye that
discerns and accounts for ideology is
inevitable and inevitably distorting
contribution would be done by her
community that her community would
provide her with the news and at the
same time a trustworthy ideologically
continent critique of the news and that
meant she could free the time the news
consumed free the time news consuming in
Parsons require time as I have no doubt
the feminist psychologist put to
excellent use you see how risky this is
admitting to flaws or license it gives
to others to sin I admired her broken
meeting her was exciting and I wasn't
closely to what she said and though I
was highly skeptical back then of the
probity of Defense
on others for news even if the morality
relying on others to your work for you
say nothing of the potentially perilous
narrowing it must follow through to
cloak thoroughly and cloister in oneself
with trustworthy ideological constant
critique consider for instance the
recent poll results indicating it fully
eighty-four percent of role fox news
viewers believe that michelle bachman is
presidential material and i'm really i
just made that pull up remember i make
things up for a living and also I don't
need newspapers though I bet the
percentage of fox news viewers who faked
michele bachmann's presidential material
is scarily high so you get my point i
was skeptical years ago when a
psychologist told me she didn't read
newspapers and I wonder now if all those
years ago she planted some permission in
my head oh this is my way of asking
whether you saw in the New York Times
yesterday the story about fake
orchestras traveling throughout the
United States I saw it because the
time's editors saw fit to put it above
the fold on the front page a rare thing
for a story about the arts usually
reserved for obituaries of very famous
movie stars and this is appropriate of
course when Elizabeth Taylor died above
the fold delicacy and insufficient they
should have canceled publication for the
day and we should have stayed home all
of us and SAT Shiva for eight days but
yesterday yesterday it wasn't a movie
start making front page headlines it was
these fake orchestras that a great name
in classical musical programming is
apparently fobbing off on with classical
music presenting organizations all over
the country you book an orchestra
billing itself as the Dublin
Philharmonic and you get a bunch of
Azerbaijan anis masquerading as Irishman
I found it hardening that the times
Dean's this a problem significant enough
to position so
prominently occupying more front page
space than a story about the way the
Japanese government concealed nuclear
risks from its citizens for decades or
the IMF guys who is accused of rape or
the happy news the New York State
Attorney General is beginning to
investigate the way the bank's rape the
economy or the entrance into a New York
house race of a tea party candidate who
believes Mexican immigrants will start a
second Civil War or below the fold a
very compelling story about the rise in
fact sometimes violent thefts from
beauty salons of human hair which who
knew is expensive I found it I found it
hard to learn from the positioning of
this story that there are still
classical music presenters and I suppose
enough people in the country who want to
hear orchestras that a consumer advisory
warning the Tchaikovsky orchestra from
st. Petersburg you bought tickets here
doesn't exist it's just some
fly-by-night ad hoc collation a pickup
musicians from I don't know boise idaho
on this scale a scale usually reserved
for e.coli of the spinach talk is
merited probably it's because I was
coming to talk to you today coming back
to my alma mater to speak to soon-to-be
graduates of the School of the Arts that
this story caught my attention compelled
me to break my phobic avoidance of
newspaper reading to read past the jump
to go inside all the way to page a 19 I
think I noticed the story because I knew
that I was coming today to talk to a
bunch of artists which is what you are
probably what you have been since your
internal structures first began to
coalesce and then somehow it some
critical juncture failed to completely
coalesce it
completely coalesce let's face it you'd
be graduating from the school of
architecture or law and medicine we
probably had a commencement speaker
doing his or her job that advised him to
describing ideals and your parents
grandparents and siblings wouldn't be
wrangling quite the same emotional
cocktail of enormous pride at your
awesome accomplishments mixed with long
suppressed and now mounting panic about
your important of possibilities I
noticed come to you today and I wanted
to bring you good news I mean good news
specifically for artists for the Arts my
graduation gift to you not role model
and a sound advisor inspiring words
about principles and goals and at least
encouragement there is plenty of good
news in the paper it turns out for
instance on page 18 I read that White
House employees want to unionize
something about which no one in my
community had informed me and that the
Obama administration when asked stayed
forthrightly that it supports the right
of workers to organize leaving me to
consider that maybe it's time to start
reading the newspaper again I think I
really stopped because of the bush
administration which seems to me a
change over the likely response of the
previous administration which would I
reasonably sure being told that you
White House employees wanted to unionize
called in the Blackwater corporation and
contracted with Halliburton to construct
interrogation cells in the Eastman
library but I digress that we have an
administration willing to endorse an
annunciator workers right to organize
seems to me good news but not
necessarily for artists and saying this
I reveal that I am primarily a
playwright forbidden by antitrust laws
from unionizing and only secondarily a
screenwriter proud member of the Writers
Guild a great union except sometimes
when it comes to arbitrary credit but I
digress or
to offer exciting sex partner benefits
on the same germs that it offers to
legally married couples but I digress
again writers because is a great Union
those of you who are television and film
screenwriters may already belong as soon
well and i will see you on the picket
lines unless of course i have a client
in production anyway casting about the
goodness trophy in my fellow artists i
seized on the story the sufficient cash
out there for serious art for it to be
worth someone's while to cobble together
fake orchestras and send them hither and
yon it's not exactly the kind of good
news for hardest adjourn cartwheels over
not genuinely great news for artists
like the above the folks front page
banner headline announcing that the
budget for the National Endowment for
the Arts has been increased tenfold to
two billion dollars something that could
have led to like one nanosecond to the
national daily debt service for the
financial bailout or equivalent to the
cost of the first 10 seconds of material
dropped on Baghdad it's not great news
like that and that has long didn't
happen because that hasn't happened news
that the arts are going to be added but
we funded affordable and accessible that
there are two now to be included in that
list of social essentials that list of
the indispensable constituent parts of
any civilization worthy of the name with
the repudiation of the insanity of
free-market ego anarchist idolatry such
fighting applies this is it needs like
that but it's the best I can do one of
your number today is my former assistant
and current barometer driving partner
and Savior and friend and Tony a
guerrilla kozlowski and she told me
talking about this which a couple of
days ago she told me that someone else
of your number a friend of hers had told
her to tell me that I should be
inspiring at least fun because you're
all sort of depressed I imagine that's
true it's in part because it's sad to
leave a place you profited from being
and probably even enjoy and your
professors who have taught you with such
perspicacity generosity and deep concern
will now be your competitors eager to
see you fail no I'm not really not
always God forgive me for saying that I
didn't mean that what's the matter of me
your teachers your elders those who have
come before are and always will be on
your side mostly over Jordan to see life
our human understanding born confidently
and daringly into the future a future
which lead or old will not get to see by
you who will we know ascend to a mastery
while we decline and we're almost
entirely pleased that this is so we know
that it is mortality itself and not more
triumph that robe area so I speak to
your faculty and saying but they will
continue to be there for you as your
parents have been but as with your
parents so with your teachers
relationships change with change in
circumstance and liberation is always
accompanied by loss and departure
liberation is always a bittersweet thing
so maybe that's what's making you blues
was the economic uncertainties here 24
alluded to attend upon graduating and
starting a life a career as a working
artist and ordinarily I'd be worried
that I'm not of the harbinger of better
is another responsibility of a
commencement speaker abrogated this is a
joyous day a day of celebration I always
look forward to speaking at commencement
side slightly given to depression myself
in commencements or reliable
circumstances in which to turn up if
you're looking for a contact high and
also I'm cheap and I like beat easy
audience and audiences at commencement
as upbeat and easy as opening night
audiences an even better than opening
night audiences because you probably
haven't had too much cheap champagne yet
and there's no intermission during which
you can take out your smart phones and
find out if the reviews are already in
and really and truly I'm very honored to
have been asked to share the day with
you and I don't want to bum anyone out
but on the other hand I'm speaking to
artists we have a special relationship
to depression too bad news of course
you're depressed Antonia's woebegone
friend whichever one of you he or she is
a nap site but I don't think any of you
look depressed not in the least you look
decided to be fabulous of course you and
your fellow graduates are somewhat
depressed you're graduating from the
school of the arts not well you know
Business School your faculty new oak it
was doing and they admitted you your
parents knew what they were doing when
they passed on their depressive
tendencies through inspiration generics
they were doing their part to ensure
that the world doesn't run out of
artists because God help the world if it
does we are here I think in part not to
report the world's agony though it's
important to do that and I can do that
as well as other things we're here I
think not to profit off the world's
agony though of course during dark
nights of the soul who among us hasn't
Lord that that's what we do he should
worry but what are the profit or what we
do with the prophets were here also to
prophesy to try to make some kind of
large sense of the agony of the world in
the name of the future in the name of
hope artist as Auden's described it
while memorializing William
yates seeing of human unsuccess in a
rapture of distress artists despite our
susceptibility to nervous afflictions on
paranoid tendencies our penchant for
self-aggrandizement its concomitant
self-pity undeserved reputation as
newspaper and news avoidant airheaded
delusional 'he's are tough people in my
experience you have to be tough to
create just ask god you have to be tough
to create specially you have to be tough
to create especially when you aren't
working within the close confines of a
tautology when the means may be mastered
but never the ends when it's not given
to you to even know the ends to refuse
to take up the means before the ends are
clear when what you are attempting to
create is finally only alive it seems to
me if I'm finished only a true deep
success if it aims the unfinished will
the incomplete able if what you create
is neither a thing nor a fixed message
nor an ossified meaning but rather a new
and attainable process an open-ended
generator of meaning a goat to
understanding a guide to wisdom rather
than knowledge uncertainty rather than
arrogance what you hope to employ in
your work is the power of deepest
affinity rather than a force you have to
be tough to do the kind of work autumn
describes in that poem about Yates your
rights follow pilot follow right to the
bottom of the night with your
unconstrained voice still persuade us to
rejoice with the farming of a verse make
a vineyard of the curse saying of human
unsuccess in a rapture of distress in
the deserts of the heart let the healing
fountain start in the prison of his days
teach the free man how to praise I'm
always a little uncomfortable since I
make my
as an artist praising what we do have
always felt that self seriousness an
artist was one of the surest ways to do
your art self in not to mention one of
the surest ways to make sure people
avoid you in the same poem Alden rights
of Yeats you were silly like us a
judgment Yates frequently made about
himself organizations to add your gift
survived at all and by all he means all
Yates is silliness well I wouldn't want
to argue error with Auden it seems to me
that Yates is silliness wasn't only the
adversary of his gift it was also an
ingredient an aspect of his genius on
catalogues Yates of silliness women like
Lady Gregory Irish politics he might
have added Yates his penchant for
mystical nonsense in which of course he
joins the splendid and splendidly silly
company the William Blake wholeheartedly
plunging into sublime silliness out of
which very serious profound and
beautiful things something almost divine
emerge and Lady Gregory after all gay
v8's a number of good lines including a
magnificent articulation of the
essential article of anyone who profess
his faith in democracy never have I now
nor at any time complained of the people
Yates of the poem the people in which
that line is quoted tells Lady Gregory
that she would complain if she had a
mind as analytical as his reasonable as
this reply is because he was a great
poet committing to telling the truth
Yates goes on to say that his heart left
up in her words and nine years later
writing the poem he tells us that we're
counting her words his head sinks
abashed this is probably why I've been
drawn to this I would have been drawn in
the story of the fake orchestras
currently medicine
concert-goers throughout the land even
if I wasn't hunting for good news to
deliver beyond the potential that the
story implies might exist for me
remuneration as an artist if you know
how to work are willing to participate
in with good con and despite the center
appropriate to producers who lie to
their public I have to confess feeling a
desire to attend the concerts of these
fake orchestras and attractions the
complexities of that experience if this
is not what it claims to be what is it
if these players are not Dubliners who
are they is what I'm hearing their
approximation of what they imagine I'm
expecting to hear and how are these
assumptions and expectations of
expectations arrived at what does all
this mean I wonder if in fact it might
be a value aesthetic and perhaps a
market value as well for a series of
Miss legally named orchestras and for
other artists too and other disciplines
operating under misnomers among the
pleasures we take from art is the very
important pleasure of being deceived
which is a way of connecting how
unceasingly existence presents us with
deception with illusion with dreams that
seem real the pleasurable engagement
with which serves to create in ourselves
an absolutely essential essential
absolutely central competence of seeing
both illusion and reality simultaneously
of reflecting the battlements and
paralysis these visions can provoke of
claiming in the face of this an agile
soul and the name of action art has its
indirect power surely we all believe
that or we wouldn't make it for that
matter consumed aren't as John Ashbery
wrote an essay about the painter
Fairfield Porter beyond the narrow
confines of the subject only one of a
number of equally important elements in
the work of art the secret business of
art gets done according to mysterious
so its own the secret business of art I
think is the awareness of meaning
meaning is never complete meaning tells
us the truth is never complete meaning
is the suspension in which violent
certainty is held and dissolved meaning
is never finished never arrived that
conclusively never exhausted never
legible to literalists and
fundamentalists to literalists and
fundamentalists meaning is a closed book
the book of mere towels and a fetish
object meaning is for people who can
handle being overwhelmed without Keeling
over meaning is for people who can
resist the urge to slither away maybe
that's why artists has such trouble with
deadlines meaning was this symmetry
meaning was this closure meaning is
impervious to sign bites and is never
singular never without its opposites
transforming itself into history comfort
with the possibility of powerlessness
may be an essential concomitant to being
an artist with its possibility not
within certainty hopefully not with
powerlessness itself the work of artists
is I think to find what's humanly
possible possibilities furthest reaches
but perhaps the work of citizens is to
find what's immediately possible I can't
tell you how your work is artist
contributes directly to your work as
citizens if in fact it does contribute
directly at all if in fact certitude and
directors directness are not as inimical
to art as despair is to politics I've
been right in place for nearly two
decades and I only know or at least I
think I know that only in activism in
activism organizing arguing fundraising
electioneering can one exercise with
some small degree of certainty once
agency is an actor in politics on the
historical stage politics as they say is
the art of the possible Kenneth cocoa to
calm called the art of the possible it
begins the art of the possible credo
vanishing is impossible lasting is
impossible being in two places at once
is impossible speaking the entire truth
is impossible instantly knowing Spanish
is
possible living in the midst of 10,000
panes of glass is impossible being
simultaneously masked and unmasked is
impossible except in art art is the art
of the possible I don't want to argue
with Kenneth coke any more than wh auden
Pope taught me when I was an
undergraduate at Columbia and I of him a
great debt as a writer and also with
someone who loves literature but I
propose that politics is the art of the
possible while art is the art of a
possibility of the impossible as you are
addict of a mystery go forth and deepen
the mystery make the impossible seem
possible bring heaven down to earth as
you are citizen added to the democracy
that is still a democracy and more than
name but not I fear unless we work very
very hard for very much longer you have
to learn as well the art of the possible
and practice it in the months and years
ahead as you are added to the divine
mystery and obviously pretty amazing at
the battery wouldn't be here graduating
from the Columbia School of the Arts on
this great day with your parents and
grandparents and spouses and children
all of whom were shipping office as you
are addicted and remarkable and soon to
be graduated a depth with diplomas and
degrees make images for the world show
the world what the heart of it is tell
the world what it means I think we are
lucky we have passed through a terrible
time there are terrible times still to
come though doubt but we're lucky this
seems to me a time of hope in America in
the world a time when America in the
world may understand the art you make
never as Lady Gregory admonished Yates
never complaining to people and read
newspapers and make art already
commenced already thank you for inviting
leash eight a day with you a million
billion muzzles tale all we count
ourselves very lucky to watch what you
had in store